[music]
>> There's a summary.
How many do you think you have put in
more?
Now, you don't know whether it's 3 hours
or whether it's 2 hours or whether it's
4 hours.
But, a normal person
many people don't have that habit of
specifying.
But, I make them to make it specific
because if you can analyze yourself, I
told you the best person to take out
mistake in you is you yourself alone.
Did I say that or not?
Yesterday I said that or not?
Or did I say today?
I'm checking.
But, fine. Whether it's yesterday or
whether it's today, someone makes a
mistake.
It's not a grave mistake as long as you
remember I said it.
The best person to analyze
yourself is you yourself.
The best person to improve is you
yourself.
If you know your weaknesses
that becomes your strength.
Knowing your weaknesses is one of the
biggest strength of a person.
I know my weaknesses
and I work on my weaknesses. It's good.
Someone who says I don't have weakness,
that's his biggest weakness.
Person saying I don't have weakness is
his biggest weakness. He's a human
being.
I'm a human being.
I make mistakes.
The world may say I do not know the
computer. I know I'm not a computer. I
know I'm not great. I know I'm not
great. We pray to Allah that may he not
hold responsible for what they say. May
he make me better than what they think
of me.
May Allah be pleased with him.
He did a dua when people praised him.
How many hours do you think more you'll
put in you'll get it? There's a summary.
One day.
One day more
to know both.
Inshallah, you have a day tomorrow.
Now, one day again is vague.
One day you mean to say 24 hours?
Of learning full time without sleep?
So, you haven't got it yet. One day is
vague. One day, yes, but how many hours
am I asking? Did I ask how many days?
What is the difference between one day
and how many hours? If I say how many
hours then you say one day that means
you require 24 hours, correct?
I did not ask you how many days. I asked
you how many hours.
For some people, one day means oh, I'm
awake for, you know, I go to office for
8 hours. So, my one day is equal to 8
hours, correct?
And you say one day you don't count the
time when you sleep.
That's why I'm asking you specifically.
How many hours? I'm not vague.
There's a difference between how many
hours and how many days, correct?
When I tell you you have 14 days, it
doesn't mean 14 days multiplied by 24
because no one can stay awake for 14
days together.
Correct?
How many hours?
24 hours.
You'll require 24 hours to memorize
without sleeping.
You're not understanding.
You require 24 hours to memorize?
24 hours?
24 hours
you require.
But, the standard requires about 2 to 4
hours. You require 24 hours.
Does anyone agree with him?
If you strive in the way of Allah, will
you require 24 hours?
If Allah helps you, Surah Al Imran,
chapter 3 verse 160, will you require 24
hours?
Brother? Yes.
If Allah helps you, you require 24
hours.
If Allah doesn't help you, how many
hours will you require?
If Allah help me, is it? If Allah helps
you, how many hours will you require?
If Allah helps you in memorizing
the first 50 Surahs, how many hours will
you require?
Three, one hour, two hours.
One hour, two hours.
Why is Allah not helping you and helping
others?
Allah is partial.
All the others, except for three, four
people, have memorized. 16 people have
memorized.
So, Allah is helping them and not
helping you.
Is it so?
No.
Then why?
Allah has promised if you strive in his
way
he'll open up the pathways.
And you say you have strived.
Who's to blame? Allah or you?
Myself.
Why?
I didn't strive.
You did not strive correctly. Maybe you
spent 4 hours like you started, it was
lost.
Then you got up.
Oh, it's 12:00. Then you went to sleep.
So, in your mind you're thinking I was
studying for 3 and 1/2 hours. Actually,
you studied only for 10 minutes.
I'm giving you hypothetical answers. It
can be one thing. Then you got up again
at 6:30 and that time you awake, you
tried for half an hour. So, actually you
spent only
the 10, 20 minutes and half an hour,
that's it.
You understand?
Because I know
when I'm tired
yesterday itself
to refer to my phone number, I require
only 10 minutes.
I TOOK 1 AND 1/2 HOURS.
WHY? I was tired. I was sleepy.
I was so tired. My wife says, "Go to
sleep.
Get up in the morning." No, no, I want
to first learn.
I WAS SLEEPY. 1 AND 1/2 HOURS. A LECTURE
of half an hour for me, 10 minutes I
require.
I cannot say I spent 1 and 1/2 hours.
I will say yes, I was tired. I was a
fool not to go to sleep.
I went to sleep and got up and spent 10
minutes, it was sufficient.
If I say I spent 1 and 1/2 hours
that means
I'm not speaking the truth.
I foolishly spent
1 and 1/2 hours not striving in the way
of Allah.
Correct?
So, if you give quality time
it has to go in your memory.
Unless you're below average. And I don't
consider yourself to be below average,
correct?
So, inshallah, day after tomorrow?
No, inshallah. For sure.
Inshallah.
If you cannot say inshallah I remember,
but I don't have confident.
Did I ask you you have confidence or
not?
Uh, because I scared you'll be asking.
Of course I'll be asking. I haven't
started yet.
See, my style of teaching is different
than my colleagues or than my students.
Now, but the colleague may be thinking
that I could have spent half an hour of
his time and didn't ask anyone. And I
said the session is over. خلاص
Without asking anyone a single Surah, I
can end the session and say I've done my
job.
Different technique.
Unconventional.
Inshallah, day after tomorrow.
Inshallah.
If you know it well.
So, now you know, but not confident.
Yeah.
You know, but you're not confident.
Huh?
You want me to try? I can try.
If you want to try, you can try.
For me, if you try also no problem. If
you don't try also no problem. What do
you want? Do you want to try?
Yeah. Okay, try. Start. Number one,
Fatiha.
Is the opening.
Number two is Al-Baqarah.
Is the cow.
Masha Allah.
Number three
is Ali Imran. Is family of Imran. Masha
Allah. Number four is
uh, the woman, uh,
An-Nisa.
Number five is Al-Ma'idah.
Is the spread of the table of spread.
Number six is is An'am.
Uh, An'am.
The meaning of An'am is, uh
uh
Can I go to number six? Number seven? No
problem. Okay.
Uh, number six is An'am. Number seven is
the height.
Al-A'raf. Masha Allah. Number number
eight is
Anfal.
Number eight is Anfal.
The meaning is
Anfal.
Okay, number nine is At-Tawbah.
Repentance.
Number 10 is Yunus.
Uh
is
J- uh, Jacob.
Uh, no. Yunus is
Joseph.
Number 11 is Hud.
Number Till number 10
you got 90% correct.
0% wrong. Two you missed. You didn't say
one.
That means 10 Surahs, 10 meanings, 90%
correct. Alhamdulilahi. Takbir! Allahu
Akbar. Takbir! Allahu Akbar. Takbir!
Allahu Akbar. Allahu Akbar. Inshallah,
continue. So, so far you're 90%.
And 10 out of 25 is
what is the percent? Who's good in
maths?
I don't know. You said you're good. Huh?
10 out of 25 is how much?
Yeah. I thought you were good in maths.
In the first 40% you got 90% correct.
Good or bad?
Good or bad? It's not good.
Not good, very good.
It's not good.
It's very good.
90% is very good or good?
Some may say excellent.
90% first time trying.
Excellent.
Okay, continue brother.
Number 11 is Hud.
Nabi Hud.
Number 12 is
Yusuf.
Jacob.
Number 13 is Ra'd.
95%
Ra'd means
Number 14 is Ibrahim.
Is uh Nabi Ibrahim. Masha Allah.
Abraham.
Number 15 is Hijr.
It's mean
the rocky track.
Number 16 Masha Allah, stop there.
Then you said in 10, two you missed out.
Out of 20 you missed out 290%. Then you
got 93, then you got 94, then you didn't
say one, you came back to 83. When you
reach 15 you didn't say three, you came
back to 90%.
The others are not doing I'm
calculating, I'm judging you. In the
first 10, 90%. 11th you said it is
92 3% then you said the 12th one, the
pairing, 94%. Then you missed the 13th.
Ra'd, then you went back to
87%. Then you said the 14th, you said
the 15th. 30 out of three not said.
90%.
Are you trying to understand?
That means
your average is 90% so far.
15 out of 25 is how much?
60% Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought Kaleem selected the cream.
The creme de la creme.
People good in maths. I am a doctor, not
an engineer.
60% test has been done of brother Vinod
Zamri.
And average is 90% good or bad?
Very good. Not good, not bad, very good.
Brother Zamri, 60% test has been done.
First 40% you got 90% right. Next 20%
90% right. Good or bad?
Neither good, neither bad. What is it?
Good.
Good?
Very good. Very good. Maybe excellent
also.
But we do it the first time, correct?
Yeah. So you underestimated yourself.
Correct?
Who was right? You or me?
You, sir.
I said two things, two problems.
Either you're telling wrong
and you said wrong in saying
I don't know well.
Correct? Okay, continue.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.